what if the US dollar stops being the
Global Currency couldn't be that big of
a deal right no it is a huge deal right
now the US dollar is what most of the
world uses for trade people trust the US
dollar it is stable and the US uses it
to pay its very high debts it has been
this way for a very long time and it has
been one reason why the United States
has kind of remained the epicenter for
economic power around the world but
that's kind of changing there's this
group of big countries Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa they're all
Rising countries and they're kind of
like why are we obeying the US dollar
why don't we create our own currency
these countries represent a huge amount
of global trade so if they decided to
make their own currency other countries
might start using it which would
diminish the power of the US dollar and
thus the power of the United States this
is just one of many ways we've been
looking into that the U.S led Global
Order is starting to have some
competition and we're moving into a new
Cold War